you might have heard about the recent
controversy surrounding San Francisco
49ers quarterback colin kaepernick long
story short the NFL player decided not
to stand during the national anthem in
protest of what he describes as
oppression in the u.s. what does that
have to do with video games well Madden
17 will be updated throughout the season
with new commentary that reflects
real-world events like this if certain
players get injured you'll hear
commentators Brandon Godin and Charles
Davis talk about it this won't apply to
just player performances but larger
events like Kaepernick's protest as well
an EA sports representative commented on
this saying Kaepernick's decision will
be briefly mentioned in game reflecting
our commitment to authenticity in madden
NFL 17 overall our new commentary will
mainly center around on-field
performance as well as major news like
trades free agency signings and injuries
madden 17 is out now on ps4 ps3 xbox one
and xbox 360 we gave it an 8 out of 10
so consider that an endorsement for the
base game and with evolving commentary
on the current gen versions it should
only get better to keep up with all the
latest from EA and the madden franchise
huddle up with gamespot
you